it's late in the evening and Jean Del
Mar is still hard at work in his office
in abidjan he's a computer specialist
working on a project to use smartphones
to register babies in rural areas yeah
the memo there are many moments when I
just want to give up even more as I
heard that a big company I already
talked with is implementing a similar
project but I'm not discouraged socket
Allison Posey similar Marilyn we didn't
Duke Roger the next morning he visits on
GaN village Jean Del Mar is looking for
young mothers to help him test his
invention his goal is to persuade the
ivorian government to implement his
program and not the one offered by a
competitor these women are taking part
in the test registration no wonder this
despair we are IT experts why can't we
recommend a very simple solution which
can be easily applied to register birds
you have been following the process
yourself I say to myself we're all
guardians of our villages children
without an official birth certificate
become phantom residents who cannot be
registered in a school get an
identification card and later be able to
vote officially they don't exist it's a
problem not only in Ivory Coast UNICEF
estimates that more than a third of
children worldwide are undocumented in
the past parents and sangam had to
travel for two hours to the next
registration office but with the SMS
service this would no longer be
necessary the registration is much more
than a formality it's vital for living
according to nadech Coomer a housemaid
well no bummer I can hardly manage with
what I earn I had my house and I have to
pay for all of that quite honestly I
cannot make it no but what's wrong but
she has registered her daughter just
verbal laughing I wish for my daughter
to go to school and become a good person
I didn't go to school that's why she has
to so that something can become of her
and that she can achieve something in
her life I prefer Valley will talk about
in the evening we meet john doe maar
again in his office he checks whether
all the data arrived but Jean cannot do
anything with it because the government
is still blocking his project whatever
looking good my dream is that we can
soon implement money bar not only an
ivory coast but also in Burkina Faso na
jiya Togo and Benin with that millions
of children could get legal identities
you saw way me nezzie saucily go
meanwhile John Del Mar is not giving up
so the two thousand babies he is already
registered through his system get
official document soon
you
you